my next
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
11 12 13 14.
welcome to the creek in the cave
hello hello hello hello
woo
loud softer whispering normal speaking
voice
17 16 15.
a lot of numbers and stuff there's a red
candles
good yeah
[Music]
says
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
all righty ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the creek in the game
without further ado let's start giving
up for your hosts this evening sound
like a thousand people for high school
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much guys
there's two of you here but we're gonna
act like there's five of you here
this is gonna be a great show it's kind
of gonna be a live podcast uh we're
gonna go on dates in front of you and
we're gonna make it super
super entertaining
uh are you guys do you guys want to go
on stage tonight is that a possibility
that's awesome thank you guys so much
for being here
we actually sold four tickets so two of
those people haven't showed up yet so
maybe you guys can go on a double date
um
but we got their money doesn't matter
we're rich
[Music]
next
comic is also the guest on the show
who's going to judge everyone and have
insightful things to say about
relationships give it up for christina
mariani
christina mariani he's going
well
i that's not what you told me
she's uh christina says she's suspicious
of men right now
i mean a little bit but who wouldn't be
you always look like you're suspicious
hans
nothing
it's just my eyes
i'm always squinting at people
what are you doing over there
but uh this is being streamed live on
youtube uh
so let's keep the racial slurs to a
minimum
no you didn't say anything racist but um
did you uh did you did you used to date
a comedian
i won't say
no
yeah well i used to date a comedian oh
and
it's very very interesting because like
their friends are your friends and like
you see them everywhere i've had like
girls that i dated that uh
started doing comedy after they see me
do comedy which i find kind of insulting
they're like i can be better than him
yeah show him yeah
i know how this guy looks like when he
comes it's not that much i can do better
than that
um but yeah i mean what do you what do
you think about the dating scene
nowadays you uh into it or no
not at all what's your least favorite
thing about dates
my least favorite thing about dates that
i don't get taken on them
i mean
no you're like one right now well i
guess i am um
but the bartender got me the drink and
you're holding all the candy to yourself
so i don't feel like it's going very
well
yeah and i made a kind of a racial slur
towards you but it wasn't
yeah you just said i look suspicious all
the time
that's fine
uh so let's see who's in the bucket i
think it's going to be a lot of dude on
dude action tonight
there's
there's one w in here
we got one lgbtqia plus i hope you're
asexual because you're gonna go on a
date by yourself and we got about six
dudes in here so
i huh know did you put your name in the
bucket
oh there's uh [ __ ]
pedro the world is against him
his life is so hard
so
oh this okay so
john timmons is in the uh
lgbtqia plus bucket
uh but shea is that you
and derek dimple are gonna go on a date
so please come around through that door
there's stairs going up don't worry
pedro i got you
you're gonna go on a date with a dude
[Music]
two dudes
so here we go derek dimple wearing his
microsoft t-shirt
looks like windows 98
uh and shay
we got two minutes and you guys are just
gonna go on a nice little date pretend
we're not here and go
hi
too
well you started i'm perfectly happy to
talk too though let me know don't go for
it oh yeah what brings you to austin or
how long have you been here i've been
here about eight months i've moved here
to start stand-up comedy that's what
i've been doing
from where uh from los angeles but you
know obviously you had like
i mean los angeles was very big uh but
also just a lot um
there was it was very locked down during
that time awesome a lot more free yeah
yeah uh where area we live in uh i live
off 290 in minnesota well maybe not
cross street okay i live south south of
austin you know buy radio coffee and
beer how about you yeah yeah um do you
know where time is
um yeah i have one i live right behind
that area okay you mean like the uh bart
uh bart yeah yeah okay
well this this is turning out to be a
great informational interview that we're
having
what do you like to do what are your
hobbies uh well uh other than this well
i mean i i like to you know i like to do
some kind of sports stuff like toss a
frisbee around or you know
i i like to play pool i like all kinds
of games and sports and stuff but my my
life is pretty narrow right now it's
mostly standard comedy
i'd say it's going well given the fact
that it's only eight months after doing
it how would you what do you do for life
[Music]
um
and time's up thank you guys so much for
going on a date
live on the show give it up for these
two
[Music]
and you stick around and just take a
seat derek and we're just gonna do a
little interview
wow that was a great date you guys found
out exactly where you guys live
you guys listed some hobbies
and then you got into the job stuff
so you're really into comedy huh
yeah
wow dude how's it going what's the
funniest thing that you've seen so far
oh the funniest thing i've seen so
far oh yeah you were laughing pretty
pretty loudly for his whole set
i was in pain
and uh what is the most concerning she's
in pain what oh
what is this child birth because women
are
hey
uh so you're consulting what's the
biggest thing that you've consulted upon
that's
um
is that part of the bounty program for
abortions or is that just
sharing blood types and blood pressures
and medical history
so you you know about hipaa
[Music]
you
didn't violate that when you shared all
the info
[Music]
is there anyone's health information you
could divulge on air right now
excuse me derek
this is a comedy show now
um
[Music]
okay i think you would win
that's not necessary no
um yeah i mean
you're going on a date in front of your
other date how does that make you feel
nice
have you ever been like the only people
in the audience before
wow the first time
where you guys came to a show that's not
very well advertised
congratulations
thanks for supporting us thanks for
signing up
yeah i mean you guys are the show and
the
audience you guys are doing everything
here
you're up there down there that's cool
uh
what did you think about the uh
the the line of questioning did you uh
was it like pretty standard date stuff
[Music]
type of yeah at all what is your
favorite type of discussion
um
anything any stupid stuff you want to
talk about what's that what's the
stupidest thing you got up to today
oh i don't know about the stupidest
thing i got up to today
but like
uh yeah i like here's a stupid thing we
could talk about like
i don't think
teachers should complain about students
passing notes if they taught them to
read and write in the first place that's
pretty stupid
right
i
mean she's insulting your very
profession the one thing that you've
only do you're very narrow right now on
comedy and
but yeah i mean teachers shouldn't
reading and writing i mean just because
i teach someone how to shoot a gun
doesn't mean i want them to shoot it at
me there's like that's a good point
that's a good analogy
there has to be some structure to the
reading and writing you can't just be
doing it
it is enabling people to have like uh
you know it's equipping people with
skills and then
you know but it's yeah but that's why
it's a stupid thought is that there are
all kinds of counter examples that
disprove it but it's right but it's a
silly thing the teacher taught gave them
the very ability to do this
yeah another punishing she's punishing
the students
for something they were able to do
but um like what is something like
because you're not passing notes around
that's not like a hobby of yours like
what's like a stupid thing that you love
to do
that's just like watching a stupid tv
show or do you like to eat something
that's like ridiculous or like
do you love to like you know
throw rocks off
overpasses
uh
i i probably do have some pretty
ridiculous
food habits uh well one one thing that i
started doing recently that i don't
think many people do in their food is to
is to incorporate lard rather than
butter
that's some pioneer [ __ ]
yeah but yeah not only is life cheaper
but it's also much healthier in terms of
its fat content butter has about five
times the amount of trans fat lard does
and so it's a better source of fuel
for the body and how does that make you
feel
not you your date
shay
[Music]
it's where the ethnic foods are like
it's for supposed to be for mexican
people
they're getting mexican lard
they're real people derek
they're not imaginary
those mexicans you know what i
[Music]
you mean tortillas and other things that
are like specifically part of mexican
cuisine and so i picked up on that it's
like oh they're marketing to people who
already shop in this section
which was supposed to be funny but now
it just makes me look like an [ __ ] it
makes you look like a racist is what it
makes you look like but uh on the show
we love mexican food uh do you
partake in lard cuisine or do you like
other types of food
[Music]
got a lot of lard on you
i think they're gonna [ __ ]
that's awesome it's getting hot
i think she's calling him a type of lard
um
that was interesting how you approached
approached
the date a lot like an interview like
you treated it in a very professional
way so you're saying like yeah it was
very surface level and that you don't
particularly like that kind of
conversation i agree with you i was like
oh that was like an uncomfortable two
minutes that we were just exchanging
information
oh i didn't think it was uncomfortable
wow
looks like you blew this you were all
about to get laid dude
that was right
yeah no it seemed like you've slot into
that very like yeah yeah christina what
do you think about this this beautiful
couple
i
hope your baby looks like you
but i definitely feel chemistry for sure
it's like it's in the movie when it's
like you hate each other and you don't
get along and then it's like a haircut
please let the woman finish
he he's not used to that um
he's used to his girlfriend being in
spain
you're too close to him
you're used to
having women be very far away from you
oh
yeah you're single now
he's available
you're here with your friend
um but yeah i mean
[Laughter]
[Music]
so you think that they have good i think
they need to go through an action
sequence together
oh yeah like a video montage just like
no you know what it's like it's like um
what's that cameron diaz in um
charlie's angel no
but kind of one more person cameron diaz
harry met sally
no it's ashton kushner and they go to
vegas and they hate each other but
they're married yes
no it's cameron diaz i've watched it a
lot of times
i like those kinds of movies
[Music]
yeah and anyways they like hate each
other but then at the end they decide
that they actually like
love each other and i feel like that's
what's happening maybe i'm wrong but
usually i'm right
together or something no
so uh have you been on a lot of dates
where it's just like informational at
the beginning but then it turns better
later
but the pandemic and trump and all that
what usually gets you like when a guy
does something because i saw your eyes
were super glazed over when you're no
not because you're boring but
yeah you look super bored when you're
talking to derek no not at
all
but i feel like there's one point in the
date when it like switches because they
do something that's just like grabs your
attention it's like is there something
that like
usually turns it around for you or like
just feel um like a weird commonality or
when you just get into this long
state of flow with someone
just based on something completely
random whether it's art or history or
movie and you guys are thinking as one
it's too late there
let us help you we're trying to salvage
this for you
every time you talk it makes our job
harder
[Laughter]
[Music]
no i i think derek is great
conversationally he uh he often goes up
to women at parties and he just starts
he has no fear of rejection
because i mean
[Music]
he's just like i'm here i'm why would i
apologize for being myself and you know
he's just always out there talking to
people
uh what how do you do that what is what
is your mindset when you go are you just
like oh look i want to talk to them let
me just go talk to them
uh i think
i think
i either have too little or too much
self-awareness to answer that question
i'm not sure but that sounded really bad
and answer that question well i mean
sure i could just [ __ ] it or like
try and figure it out
um but i well i've always liked to talk
to people and i i think i don't have an
accurate concept i don't have a very
strong conception
of how i look to other people and so
there's just a lot um so so it's just
easier to have an impetus of like oh
let's do something rather than like what
do i look like doing this
oh
that's that's smart
it's good that you're [ __ ] in that
way because
then you don't have that part of
yourself that's like
thinking about yourself so if you were
like
to go up to ridge right now in the back
what would you talk about what was the
first thing you'd say oh [ __ ] well i'd
say like how recently he was
dressed like a really hot hipster and
now he's got the cowboy hat thing going
on again so he would compliment his
physical beauty
he's a beautiful man for sure okay
maybe you should have been in the lgbt
bucket buddy no i've kissed three men
and it's never done anything for me
sexually you didn't get that the first
time
welcome to the roast of dairy dipper
we're all taking shots at derrick
tonight
christina please uh
please please stick him with him
i don't know i feel a little bad now
he gets off on it he loves the
not what i'm not attention
i'm not enjoying being put down
i'm enjoying this we're putting you down
to put you up it's like a roller coaster
yeah she'll feel sorry for you and then
maybe she'll [ __ ] you i don't know
i don't think so though what kind of uh
men are you into in terms of dating are
you into like the strong
silent type or the
weak loud type
[Music]
because
we got a pretty loud one over here
strong and loud that's hot
just lifting you up and yelling at you
well i like someone who can you know
i think he just negged you
let's not attack the physical appearance
of your dates
what
no no no no it does sometimes
he's doubling down
[Music]
i think she's just high
um and she's also way out of your league
but that's not here nor there but uh
what do you
what kind of women are you into in
general derek
well
there's such a wide variety
um
but like a woman being being into me is
a is a big help because so shay's out of
the picture
i like a woman who's going to have a lot
of fun i like the woman who's physically
affectionate i like a woman that i can
talk to
about things i have both an intellectual
and emotionally intelligent conversation
and someone with two functioning eyelids
so you're out of the picture
burn bam
what the [ __ ]
keep it going for christina her last
time on the show
um
no derek no
stop trying zara derek
you're ruining my show
now um i think this is a great date and
it was very interesting you guys are
both very vocal people that are can
articulate what you're going through and
this was fascinating to delve into your
minds
and i thank you guys very much for
coming on the show and i hope you enjoy
the rest of it as an audience member
thank you
see you guys
wow what a date
i felt like um sparks were flying yeah
oh he's touching her uh oh
we'll need you to sign something before
you go
yes uh any uh sexual assault that
happens on the show is part of the the
show it's like it's not real it stays
so you guys can come here and figure me
if you want you know it's
i signed up for it anyways uh
so are you uh you're excited what should
we do next should we have two guys come
up here i think so let's have
one from the lgbtqi plus bucket
uh
very flat
john timmons is that you
john timmons isn't here a lot of people
were signed up this is why i don't
please don't sign other people up if
they get here they can sign up um
colin o'meara is not here
evan
evan and let's do pedro valenzuela oh
yes where's pedro
you guys are gonna go on a blow date
this is gonna be great
we only got one more person left in the
bucket i don't know who he's gonna go on
a date with
i think it's just gonna have to be by
himself
and
two straight men
talking to each other for two minutes
here we go and go talk
what's up pedro
so am i topping
how's this gonna work did you pay for
dinner that's how i usually settle that
you got this beer
thanks brother it's like a fourth of a
beer kind of a cheap date
to be honest i like you though i like
your eyes
you have a clean shave it's always good
hair is nice
don't compliment me or anything
[Music]
but yeah that's been nice nice biceps
that's fair you know how many push-ups
can you do
a lot a lot double stitch
dead ass
no hands can you do well both hands that
doesn't make sense
i think so it's been a while since i got
that risky out there though
well this is going to be a problem
because i have aids so
it's going to be very risky it's just a
nasty rumor that's been spread about me
by the illuminati so i wouldn't worry
about it but
you know conspiracies
yeah
yeah what's your favorite one
um i mean the classic is bushed in 911
right i've been in the past it's like
nice i feel like i got in early how old
were you when
9 11 happened
i was in kindergarten from kindergarten
because i don't really remember it
i was in the third
i was in sixth grade
okay
nice so you got a little cougar action
here tonight
i'm not sure what that means like you're
older than me i think that was oh okay
yeah so you're getting cougar action
i'm getting hot young boy action yeah
i'm legal though
and time
wow what a great date give it up for
these guys for going on a date together
i was super brave of you guys to do that
as straight men
uh
i can't believe pedro is older than
someone
that shocked me because
you live in a car
it's true i live in a car i forgot to
tell you that it's probably going to
change things
wow i mean
you are aristic i like the dance side
thank you i feel like they have more
chemistry than
definitely peter did most of the talking
that makes sense that he would top he
offered him the lone star that's
apparently all it takes to
[ __ ] your butthole
um
how old are you they're pretty young for
if you're
oh mid-20s pedro you're 32
31
holy [ __ ] dude
how old are you i'm 32.
i had no idea you were that old
you're older than me
yeah i know
um
[Music]
you complimented his eyes
as a viewer yeah totally
you call them
yeah they're all comedians
yeah
although shea was hilarious yeah shea
was
roasting derek she was quick with it
uh that's a compliment
you're not that
okay
really what have you tried
to be racist
he's wearing his grandmother's glasses
he's wearing his grandmother's glasses
they're too into each other
they're making a connection this is good
to be here live for this yeah you said
you're into the 911 conspiracy theory
[Music]
yeah very into that
is it like a joke or is that like you
actually think it might be true
okay well did you know that jet fuel can
sort of weaken steel beams so it doesn't
melt it but you don't have to get to the
melting point
to make the steel beams fall down
you're welcome hopefully yeah i'm into
uh 911 truther movement
um
so you're in kindergarten during the
whole thing like uh did you have to go
back to your home when uh when that
happened
that's the problem with these zoomers
yeah they already
they already forgot
dude
[Applause]
[Music]
they go together like 911 in bush right
yeah
they look like the two towers oh
there's going to be some double
penetration
let's bring shea back up here it's like
you're getting pegged yeah but uh yeah i
mean his [ __ ] is older it's weaker
it's probably easier to push it in there
you have a young taut [ __ ]
[Music]
um
aids illuminati
that was an interesting line that you
went with
uh do you believe in conspiracy theories
pedro
i mean
i believe in the truth
what is your favorite conspiracy theory
uh
probably
[Music]
okay
um
you also talked about push-ups you said
you could do multiple are you uh into
sports are you a pretty athletic kind of
guy
nice we actually have a basketball group
chat you should be a part of it
okay just don't talk about anything
except basketball yeah pedro
pedro
pedro's always like can you sign me up
for this mic
it was a basketball group chat
always
one time
well you were stopped immediately
we talked about
nba
basketball like we're gonna go to peace
park they play a lot of peace park
oh nice did you play
there's too many
yeah so you like shooting around more
than actually playing no i usually play
like a squad over on riverside but today
i just wanted to get like a great cardio
nice
police
[Music]
yeah where do you tuck at
nice you can't name it
what uh what kind of technology do you
do software engineering or lgbt commerce
huh selling stuff online oh do you do
sales or
yeah
okay so does shea
yeah you guys have a lot in common you
guys can consult each other
i need two times
[Music]
you want to get drunk and consult
sounds like a hot date
let's consult each other on yeah
we were actually here
oh filthy show yeah nice
thank you i had a good time that was fun
is he trying to make a sale right now
[Music]
he's getting jealous you better be
careful
yeah dude why are you [ __ ] stepping
up on my man bro
[Music]
a threesome
we could do it
i mean
how it's been going maybe i should have
you know
yeah you still can
huh
we can mix and match
i don't know i feel like you're really
trying to hold it together you're in
love with shay aren't you
that's good for you
just like the twin towers don't exist
or a hologram
so yeah i mean you're sort of dating her
you're here with shay now uh
so
what is your
what do you think is uh
going to happen in the next five years
are you do you have a
idea of who you're going to end up with
[Music]
or any plans do you want children
i do want children probably not within
the next five years not with pedro
it's possible is it science dude
[ __ ] science is getting crazy i
haven't heard about that but yeah
would you vote for
i'm still this is serious dude i'm
looking for boys which election
[Music]
uh 2020.
howie mandel uh which bush was that
the other one
yeah jeb bush
yeah
really yeah okay
the exclamation mark at the end that's
dude
[Music]
you keep up to date you uh watch the
daily show or something
that's too bad
uh
i don't i watch the daily show clips on
youtube sometimes
if i agree with their opinion
who uh
what do you watch on youtube what's on
your feed right now
actually a lot of basketball
nice so you're really into basketball
yeah
i would say so do you watch that white
dude that like goes to like harlow that
beats black people at basketball
that feels wrong
that's like motown
in basketball
but uh
that's awesome yeah
pedro you think you could beat him one
on one
probably not i'm terrible at sports i
can beat you at like pokemon you play
pokemon
like
that's not really one novel yeah i guess
you could yeah you can poke battle
double battles you have to gather
i got a trick room team
blow your [ __ ] mind away dude
okay thank you guys so much for coming
that was a great date
our first gay date
with our first gay couple pedro and evan
can't believe how gay they were together
beautiful beautiful gay couple
how did you feel about that gay couple
i thought it went better than the
straight couple really yes i mean they
got to know each other more yeah they
were bonding they were talking about
being on top 911 all hot topics you know
that's what i'm saying
hot topics just like
pedro's wardrobe is from hot topic
yes uh so this is a straight bucket this
is the male bucket is dale mexican here
and dale mexican's not here
dale mexican and ridge hershberger you
guys are gonna [ __ ]
hey molly did you want to sign up
i want you to you're the only woman here
all right rich and dale they're gonna go
on a date
and go ahead and go do your thing guys
[Music]
are you gonna talk to me or not
she point your thing out right now dude
[Music]
oh you're so straightforward
listen
straight up
if you don't take that dick out i'm
leading
so
do you like basketball
it's pretty good
do you like mechanical bowls no
you ever see that guy that does like the
mechanical bull over there and he's just
like trying to get hot [ __ ] up there
all the time yeah that's me
oh [ __ ] that guy you got you're a nice
[Applause]
and time thank you guys so much for
going on a date together give it up for
this lovely gay couple brokeback
mountain up here
so do you often on dates turn to the
people around you at restaurants and be
like you want to see this girl's vagina
[Music]
to be honest on a date
that's a interesting move i hope you
will have lots of success with that
it's funny because ridge was going with
the the gay voice right away with a
girly feminine voice and i i thought
it'd be you dale i thought richard i
have to
his face does all the talking for him
but uh so you guys
[Music]
think that you guys would go on a date
and
ridge would be the woman or do you think
that's outdated do you think you guys
could both be
be straight and just be men two men go
back and forth to be honest
yeah that's good
i'm more male
uh i think
like
you know around the house i'm more i'm
more female for sure you like to clean
you like to cook
yeah you don't want ridge uh doing any
dishes or anything
it's gonna make a mess
[Music]
nice
even though his beard looks like a
brillo pad i don't think he'd be good at
doing dishes
but uh rich you uh you enjoyed your day
with dale you guys are
ever had friends
wait we should stop some spit later
how do you feel about
how do you feel about brokeback mountain
do you think that ruined
cowboys
lots of lots of stuff that you don't
want to talk about happens up there
yeah i think that's why
to be honest
actually that was george bush
he did 9 11 and killed heath ledger
at least
[Music]
so christina what do you think about
these two studly men going at it
uh
she's speechless
do gay guys go on adam do the same thing
that lesbians do for straight men
um not with stem but the couple before
them yes
do you like the emotional connection
them too pedro and
yeah yeah i felt like i don't know evan
was being sassy with him you know it's
just kind of like
maybe pedro
evan was playing yeah evan was there's
an elephant
what is it
the elephant is your penis
the elephant is that we all want to date
christina but we're
stuck over here
we're stuck over here trying to date
each other for some reason
oh god
dale's got a very beautiful face uh
how is it walking down 6th street do a
lot of women just throw themselves at
you no actually not
what happens
they love you yeah
that's awesome man what is what is like
a line that they say to you
you're so
[Music]
the cute you are pretty cute
that's why ridge couldn't get his eyes
off of you
yeah i don't give off like the
alpha energy i give off like he'll
switch sides for me that's the time i
give off
[Music]
why did you tell him to do that to see
if i could
and
and it happened how did it make you feel
put off
you didn't like it
it's like now i don't respect your
and we just [ __ ] morning
right there
tom you've had fun involving your
parking lots yeah i figured a girl had a
drive-through there yeah
i'm sure that was pretty good
yeah she was into it that's good and
then you just did you wash your hands
before you ate or though not really just
sort of do one of these air dry it
that's the best piece
yeah i mean i put my face in there why
would i
it's just another barrier but
yeah so you you made him kiss jack fluge
and then you
were like ah you did it now i don't
respect you like do you see like how
that's bad for feminists yeah
no i think it's
i think it's really good for feminists
it's like get them to play your little
reindeer games and then don't respect
them it's like what more do you want
so you just use them like a boy toy
two little boy toys kissing each other
that's really hot it was hot honestly
but
imagine the two of us we have zero
chemistry yeah no there was chemistry
though and there was what kind of
chemistry did they have i don't know
like ap
chemistry
no
because you probably would have kissed
them too
[Music]
hey guys i want to join in
yeah
you guys have all the fun without me
uh but that's that's awesome dude you
kissed jack fluge
how did it happen did you just do that
peck or was it like a little bit of
prolonged action
it yeah so it's kind of up to me
that's a little cocky
he's bi so he was definitely into me
like every bi guy would be into you he
was like hey cutie and then planted one
on me right
it's a good point all right i didn't go
in first i don't know if he wanted it
but i did it
how long was this kiss it was just a
quick one how many times have you
thought about it since honestly like
three or four times in the shower
it's a real stat really yeah that's
awesome man
so uh on sixth street you don't get a
lot of action from women i think you'd
do really good in korea or asia because
they're more into effeminate men
but you're pretty athletic you're pretty
sporty right you play basketball
you think you could beat evan one on one
i don't know who evan is but
that's evan right there
we can do one of those jerry springer
ones you know what i mean
see who's the dad this smells like jerry
springer
a little bit huh
who wants to kiss
who's who's gonna kiss right now on
stage
this is going out live on youtube
yeah there's a lot of comedians here
oh nice
but uh yeah i mean if you guys don't
want to kiss uh maybe
someone could stick a finger in
someone's butt
that's better right
uh
i'm just kidding i'm not i was gonna be
like you can do it to me but i don't i
don't actually want to do that
i'll kiss i'll kiss someone real quick
but no we don't have to stick to that
level i feel like you should kiss stalin
i don't want to kiss rich because ridge
is going to think about it and then
murder me later
like he's kind of like repressed
homosexual conservative tendencies
it'll break him
no actually me and rage live together
really yeah me and rage live together
doesn't ridge sleep on your couch yes
and he seems like he would be like but
he's actually really environmentally
conscious i caught him
no like i caught him drinking my bath
water a few times
[Laughter]
maybe that's
i mean that's why i'm so attracted to
him right now
uh does ridge recycle or does he just
throw everything in the trash
um
for men i don't know anymore now does
rich bring any uh women home to his
couch
um yeah
but he's related to them
his sister the sex sounds hot still
that's hot yeah i feel like you guys
should know that he's
not in bread but
his clothes
yeah yeah that's what i meant i didn't
mean to
so you'd rather wrong with that
you know
king shame
yeah incest is a kink
[Music]
that's your sexual orientation
we should have an incest bucket right
here
just ridge and all his family are in
there how many people their first kiss
was somewhere they were related to
nobody
who else here is a trump supporter raise
your hand
ridge is our resident trump supporter so
what do you think about uh you know
let's go brandon do you think that do
you have you ever said that i think
that's offensive and i don't like to say
things that are like that vulgar
and i don't think you should do all
those things because i wouldn't want
that being yelled at
yeah
i don't know if you know this but this
is austin and uh we love a little
brandon here if you know what i mean i
mean gay sex
uh brandon brandon for everyone i say uh
i'm slowly losing it
uh so
i mean you're here on a date with a dude
on a frilly table we could use this
picture as blackmail you can never go
back to pennsylvania again
[Music]
no we didn't have a we had oh
we didn't have a gay family
he did have a gay family member
let's put that out there clip it meme it
once
in the
living in san 90s
that's like your dog went to a farm out
outside upstate
you used to have an uncle but we sent
him to san francisco to die of
that's hot dude you have it running in
your bloodstream it's probably in there
somewhere we just gotta get dale to suck
on your [ __ ] it'll come right out
bring out your
drill bits
all right let's get let's get a straight
couple up here
thank you guys so much for coming up
and doing this for
us uh
let's see
we got some women
here is it men
see it ridge
can't miss an opportunity to touch men
this guy
uh everyone signed up for the woman
bucket
rachael girl
this says rachel parenthesis girl is
going to be
coming up here
let's get the rachel girl up here
and going on a date with rachel girl is
going to be
jason rodriguez man
let's go
let's see the sparks flying
let's get the cupid beautiful
woman wow i wish i was going on a date
with her uh but it's jason and rachel
girl
hello
i'm good how are um good you're doing
good yeah i'm in town from boston
for a week that's fun yeah you uh red
sox man
you know i've never been to a game i'm
kind of new
to the whole baseball thing oh yeah you
never heard of it before
yeah so are you from boston
no i'm from saint louis
yeah and i moved to boston
[Music]
your ex was in saint louis
it's really nice
how about you i'm from california from
california how long have you lived there
uh like my whole life from from
yeah i'm here with my best friend over
there
elena we're here to get you know a
little shitty and
you just enjoy ourselves away from our
kids and
have a good time
[Music]
thank you guys so much for going on a
date
wow a lot of a lot of information was
said a lot of state names
st louis city names boston you guys have
been all over the two of you combined
have really traversed this this great
country of ours so if you
good food you said you like tacos
filipino
you liked a lot
blood or something
[Music]
well you have a couple eggs that grow up
and turn into children
that's kind of hot
uh so is st louis x is that the father
wow so you got a crazy baby daddy
[Music]
can we get a shot for rachel she's a
girl
you know the buckets
because the buckets have like w for
women on it so you didn't actually have
to write girl like right
here
oh
thank you rob
rob just
did rob misgender you or
no
you're a woman not a girl
you're a woman that gave birth to girls
what is the gender of your children
nice
so
two girls
are you all synced yet
nothing
you're a filipino filipina uh jason's
mexican uh jason how did you uh do you
guys think that uh if you guys marry she
won't have to change your last name
[Music]
you know a lot of women like erase their
history by taking on the name of a man
if you think
[Music]
yeah you shouldn't do that ladies
christina would you ever
christina would you ever change your
last name if you found a nice guy with a
nice last name
it depends yeah would you take me out on
dates
definitely he's your husband
then yeah sure you know
i have pretty low standards at this
point i think
if you want your name to spread it take
christina mariani she's willing to
change it her last name is out for rent
you can just replace it with whatever
you want like you can call it pepsi cola
i think they like each other the date is
going better than i could imagine
free drinks for their beautiful day
yeah you definitely don't want to get
too drunk
oh then drink away
who wants her to take a shot right now
take a shot take a shot take a shot
take a shot
[Music]
okay we're gonna have the beautiful
couple take a shot together
uh but in the meantime you guys talked
about the red sox you had no idea
baseball even existed as a sport
what is your favorite uh thing to watch
on tv if it's not sports
lifetime
[Music]
okay no
i've never thought of that do you have a
favorite victim
do you have a favorite victim
do you have a favorite
favorite case
you know scream what is
[Music]
that's not really true crime it's
actually a fake movie but
yeah
what what's like a true crime thing that
you enjoyed watching
on youtube makeup
do you believe in 911 was an inside job
[Music]
yes
time is ticking
[Music]
you think so
anyways we're sponsored tonight
well you're just
you're the most interesting person on
this day right now
uh take a shot you two you beautiful
couple
you guys are gonna [ __ ] tonight at least
a hand job
something
i feel like they should kiss yeah you
guys should kiss yeah after the show
drive on air
if you guys wanna kiss you're totally
welcome to
kiss
so jason uh you're from california
you've lived there your whole life
and you escaped uh
do you think that a lot more people are
gonna come because california sucks and
texas is awesome
[Music]
where's your favorite part of texas
[Music]
you told me to ask him questions
i try to ask him a question you just
love the spotlight
you want to be on a true crime podcast
or
uh jason how do you like texas so far
[Music]
yeah it's humid sometimes
about to get wet jason huh
i tried to be douchey
it wasn't a good job
i was tired of being a douche i'm glad
that you're taking the reigns so rachel
uh you uh you like tacos
you're filipina and white who is white
your dad or your mom okay
classic asian interracial couple
maybe next time we can get a dude to
[ __ ] a white girl
uh so how was it growing up was your was
your mom really strict
[Music]
i i like going deep
but
[Music]
yeah did your mom make you do your
homework was she strict
she was
options higher relaxed a normal voice
so you were
you had a rough childhood
and uh how did you
[Music]
my childhood is a black box
i'm only here to facilitate your
relationship with jason rodriguez
uh if you had to go on a date with jason
anywhere in boston where would you take
him fenway
you've never been to boston
oh okay
[Music]
lobster rose you're from saint louis
when you think about
i don't know you're in people work at
the grocery store they're from there
well anyway that's the guy where the
minced garlic is and he was confused by
what i said he's like what the hell are
you garlic he was like you mean the
garlic
wow
she's the comedian
she's doing bits on us
[Music]
yes people in boston talk weird jason
would you ever locate to boston home of
some great comedians
[Music]
can i get my microphone a little louder
[Music]
so you guys are such a beautiful couple
i just want to make sure you guys uh
seal the deal tonight uh what is your
favorite jason what is your favorite
position
oh
[Music]
plane
um
i'm thinking
she would have set a baseball position
but she doesn't know anything about
baseball i would have said like center
field or left left field
but uh yeah jason likes doggy style are
you standing up or are you kneeling on
the bed i like standing up i don't like
kneeling i don't like my knees
so she's on the bed
and you're standing up
[Music]
[Music]
hey uh rachel i actually have another
question for you
what is your favorite position
[Music]
of the plane
of the plane
her favorite position
her favorite position is the dudes in st
louis and she's in boston
[Music]
okay uh any questions for this lovely
couple christina
i really see you guys together i feel
like it's a close it's been great yeah
how do you feel being a dad
yeah
do you think jason would be a good dad
i mean
if i said yes like i would be extremely
judged right now
[Music]
what kind of dad
[Music]
i mean
either way like
wow this has been like a quick five
minutes like
damn
we're trying to find you a beautiful
husband
it only takes a quick five minutes
that's how your children are conceived
is five minutes
but uh
thank you rachel and jason for coming on
this date
let's get another one up here quick do
you want to pick one a woman okay i'll
pick somebody i'll pick
a man
elena j
elena j girl and ray chenevey
elena j girl and ray chenevy
here's elena
[Music]
elena
she's very particular i have an accent
and ray chenevey
oh
ray genevieve left he missed out on
getting laid tonight
gabe bickford
is going to go on a date with
[Applause]
elena will be a good one
i feel like these two will connect you
guys get two minutes talk to each other
and hit it off
all right go ahead all right what's up
elena all right you reminisce man
yeah ask me something what's up what
questions should i ask for
a question
where are you from here
yeah yeah pretty much greater austin
area are you from boston too
no st louis
malachi and sophie that's a good name
better my name's my name is gabe my name
is elena you have a good
and time's up for this lovely couple
thank you guys so much for going on a
date together
you know i hate when i'm on a date with
a girl and her friend is just like yeah
that's a good name
i support this thanks for bringing your
friend on this wonderful date
she goes everywhere
good the mom and mean girls she's like
you need anything condoms
do you have condoms for your friend
you don't want to
be a mom of 302.
that's a hundred more
um gabe with the rapid fire questions
i don't think there's a question you
didn't answer i think you guys can get
married now
you know where she's from
you are really interested in the
etymology of her name
has a spanish name
you know a lot of people have spanish
names and they're from mexico right they
don't necessarily go to spain to get
yeah if i said that if she was from
spain
[Music]
unfortunately
most people in america are from america
it's this weird thing about us
but uh you are from st louis you're born
and raised
[Music]
are you mexican
no
what's your race
check
holy [ __ ]
an irish
jesus christ you should have guessed
that you would have definitely been in
with a checking irish
who's ever gonna guess that
check please is
what i would say for gabe right now is
he kind of [ __ ] it up this guy no uh
you guys are doing great uh
202 in austin
is the uh is uh do you have like a
a dad a baby daddy
in the picture
are you single
[Applause]
are you co-parenting
no
gabe
but
okay so the father of my children is not
their biological father
nice so you're in a relationship right
now yeah
well thanks for going on a date with
gabe
that's awesome
just don't tell him that
i mean it's on youtube but just don't
take him out block youtube for for a hot
minute do you need a babysitter
willing to be the hot babysitter
you'll [ __ ] your husband too
um gabe are you uh good with children uh
yeah
he's like 22 he is a child
he'll be watching frozen two alongside
your children he'll be enjoying it
and then you guys can go on a date
and gabe you could watch their children
yeah
i could
you want to get
you want to get his number right now
get
that's awesome there's a pen right there
he's gonna this is the first time
someone has gone so far on a date with a
married woman
this is
we're breaking
oh so it's not even real
so you might [ __ ] the hot babysitter
there's this number
good job gabe
[Music]
you're doing great sweetie
yeah that's insane yeah
you know
you can like we have all the streaming
oh
[Music]
gabe is going to be able to sleep
indoors tonight
he's not going to have to sleep in his
mom's house anymore
uh
so you guys are a wonderful couple um
you live in austin uh you live in the
west hills area
you have a real job
[Music]
my job is taking care of my children
nice
that's a real job
okay going strong with the married woman
uh
letterwood uh we found out that gabe has
a bit of a speech impediment uh he was
as a child he's not really from st louis
you would get shot if you're in st louis
right now
[Music]
letter wood what's letter wood like is
it kind of the hood
leatherwood i swear to god leonard
someone else just corroborated what i
said who was that
it's a jail
where was my dad in jail
[Music]
gabe is finding out his dad was mexican
what's what's leonard what's leonard
wood
it's
like
like
it's kind of a dump
i don't know i've only been there like
once maybe
okay
it's like what kind of base is it
oh are you an army brat gabe yeah
okay
so he was either in jail or he really
was on base
[Music]
so you moved around a lot as a kid oh no
like my favorite colleen when i was like
a kid and that's why i live here now
nice
so uh
so have you ever thought about joining
the military and serving our great
country
wow not a patriot hopefully
hopefully she's okay with that um
do you like traders to our country is
are you willing to
have that instilled in your child's
brain
[Music]
what are you looking for in a babysitter
um you know i just want my kids to be
like alive by the time
that's important
not bothered really
don't bother her children
they'll go to sleep
[Music]
they don't
[Music]
i mean even if they cry they'll be okay
let them cry
cry it out
don't even console them just like yeah
[Music]
i mean
what do you think about this date
oh um i think it's pretty good i was
gonna ask if you would beat her kids
like if they were crying it's not like
yeah because they're too they can't say
if you did that they don't know
oh my son can he he has a very big
vocabulary and he's a very big smart ass
got it so no beating the kids anymore no
so i guess you can't get away with it
can't beat the kids
[Music]
that's too bad
he was gonna use your kids as a punching
bag
thankfully christina sniffed it out
[Music]
yeah i never got therapy and i got beat
as a kid i'm fine
if you want your kid to turn out like
christina
make sure you to smack him every now and
then yeah
weapon of choice belt also not going to
be funny you want to have boring kids
yeah a little trauma is good
not a lot a little
that make my life easier like you didn't
get beat i can tell
that's nice i mean me too in a way you
know kinkier
all right that's the end of the show
thank you guys so much for coming out
christina's got a lot of work to do
in therapy
no this is all i needed hans i'm thank
you so much for doing this thank you for
asking me this was so much fun what uh
what couple do you think has the best
chance tonight of getting laid it's
weird i feel like the couples got
progressively like
hotter
are you telling me
um
but
pedro pedro
evan that was the couple that i think
yeah there was a clear dynamic there
there were there was one that was really
annoying and one that was very nice and
good at basketball yeah they're both
into basketball we won't see who's who
but
no i didn't say that pedro yeah pedro
you said that
i don't know
thank you guys so much for coming out
and uh tip your bar stuff and drive home
safe thank you guys
good night
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sorry if i said of your eyelid
comment that wasn't nice
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]